إسرائيل في حالة حرب مع حماس تقول إن رئيس
الوزراء حماس شنت اليوم
هجومًا مفاجئًا كبيرًا على إسرائيل جوًا برا
وبحرًا، بالطبع،
قُتل 70 شخصًا وأصيب أكثر من 900 آخرين،
على الرغم من أن المسؤولين أخبرونا
أن رقم القتلى في الواقع لا بد أن يكون كثيرًا
أعلى في الوقت الحالي، وبعض
المواطنين الإسرائيليين والجنود الإسرائيليين
محتجزون كرهائن وأسرى حرب.
تحدث رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي نتنياهو
للتو مع الرئيس جو بايدن بينما
يستعد المجتمع الدولي
لصراع لم يتوقع أحد أن يصل
إلى هذا الحد على الأقل.  نتلقى الآن مقطع
فيديو جديدًا يظهر حماس وهي تأخذ
أسيرًا إسرائيليًا، وقد تم
تحديد الموقع الجغرافي لهذا الفيديو بواسطة CNN، ولكننا نريد أن
نحذرك من أنه أمر مزعج، إنها حرب، هذه
في غزة، يمكنك رؤية امرأة حافية القدمين يتم
سحبها من صندوق سيارة جيب  على يد
مسلح ثم أجبرها على الجلوس في
المقعد الخلفي للسيارة، وكان وجهها ينزف
ويبدو أن معصميها مقيدين
خلف ظهرها. ويبدو أيضًا أن سيارة الجيب
تحمل
لوحة ترخيص تابعة لقوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية مما يشير إلى أنها
ربما تكون قد سُرقت وتم إحضارها  إلى
غزة